i saw two campaign ads over the weekend
that i think will show you
the distinction we're talking about here
the first one was from the much maligned
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
march retailer green
uh airs this ad to convince people of
her toughness on socialism
nancy pelosi is sneaking the green new
deal into the 3.5 trillion dollar budget
and in 2022 i'm going to blow away the
democrats socialist agenda
[Music]
[Music]
go to the website below and sign up to
win my 50 caliber gun before joe biden
bans it
okay i love this commercial okay and the
whole knock on marge retailer green
right she's kooky
she's crazy she's extreme and then she
does this this commercial where she's
there with a barrett 50 cow and she
blows up a toyota prius that says
socialism on it and i think she really
blew it up i mean i think all those
various angles were of the car actually
exploding in the middle of a field
and she says go to this website and you
can win my gun
okay
now i think that's a pretty effective ad
and i think she's pretty popular in our
district so i think it's obviously
working compare that to georgia governor
brian kemp
who has
had some problems with the conservative
base specifically with how he handled
the various shenanigans around the 2020
presidential election
kemp
tries to make almost the exact same ad
but take a listen let me know if you
think it's as persuasive
i'm brian kemp i'm so conservative
[Applause]
i blow up government spending
i own guns
that no one's taken away
my chainsaw's ready to rip up some
regulations
i got a big truck
just in case i need to round up criminal
illegals and take them home myself
yep i just said that
i'm brian kemp if you want a politically
incorrect conservative that's me
i don't think the cringe is ever gonna
leave my face you know how when you were
a kid and your mother said don't cross
your eyes they'll get stuck that way
that's what's gonna happen to the
cringing that's happening on my face
right now from from watching that
commercial we'll get to more of that in
a second first though
i want you to think about
those things you look at online you know
you go you open up your internet browser
maybe you open up the incognito browser
you know and you type in those websites
you don't want anyone to see
you know i'm talking about dailywire.com
okay you're not some of those
conservative websites they could get you
in trouble mister
to keep your data private i would
strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn you know i mean i'm making a
joke about if you're looking at naughty
things on the internet but increasingly
even if you're looking at perfectly
wholesome things perfectly ordinary
things that are politically incorrect
that could pose a real problem for you
because there are a lot of data brokers
out there their whole business is to buy
and sell your data
worst part is
they don't have to tell you who they're
selling it to they don't need to get
your consent use expressvpn it's super
easy okay
data harvesters use your ip address
to uniquely identify you and your
location when i use expressvpn i click
the button expressvpn goes on it's very
simple on my phone and on my computer
and then i don't need to worry about it
if you're like me and you believe your
data is your business secure it with the
number one rated vpn on the market
that's expressvpn.com michael get three
extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com michael to learn more
brian kemp has to open up with this with
this phrase three words
i'm so conservative
right you'll notice marjorie green
doesn't open up with i'm so conservative
because people know okay that lady she
had a big sign that said transgenderism
is fake or some version of that outside
of her congressional office which is
right across the street from some huge
pro-trans activist okay right across the
the uh hallway so she's
she lays it all on the table okay she
doesn't need to say i'm margerating i'm
so conservative so brian kemp does
and says i blow up government spending
but he didn't blow up government
spending govern something exploded
behind him but but notice he didn't
shoot it he wouldn't oh gosh he wouldn't
want to be caught firing a gun that
could be misinterpreted by people right
so they both blow something up but with
brian kemp it just happens behind him
with marjory green she pulls the bear at
50 cal then he says i've got my guns
that nobody's taken away again but you
see he'll hold the gun then he'll blow
something up then he'll hold the gun but
he certainly won't shoot the gun then he
moves on he says and i've got this big
truck you know it's like a saturday
night live parody of a conservative
commercial because i've got this big
truck in case i need to round up any
criminal illegals
listen to that phrase let that sink in
criminal illegal
a little redundant wouldn't you say
those words mean the same it's like yeah
if in case i need to round up any
illegal illegals but what he's doing
here it's a very specific wording he's
not saying he's going to round up all
the illegals
he's going to round up only the illegals
who are committing additional crimes who
are here in the united states which of
course he's not going to do then he says
i've got this chainsaw
to rip up regulation you know this kind
of 90s and 2000s just like we need to
privatize everything and that's going to
lead to a conservative country
i'm sorry and then after he said the
illegal line what did he say he said
yeah i really said that
yeah i'm really impressed with myself
because hey i know how out there that
was yeah if you want a politically
incorrect governor vote for me now look
i'm not making any
comment about the efficacy of marjorie
green or brian kemp in office i'm not
making any point on their record i'm
making a point
on authenticity
marjorie greene
really is who she says she is
brian kemp is not
he is playing a role he's playing this
rowdy rough tough conservative but it's
not it's not real some some operative in
washington dc wrote that commercial and
didn't do a very good job about it and i
think what we're seeing right now with
what happened at the fake january 6th
rally and what's going on right now with
the public health narrative collapsing
we are now seeing more clearly than
perhaps ever before
the stark difference between the
appearances
and the realities of our political
situation i'm so glad you liked that
clip if you wouldn't mind leave me a
comment here on youtube subscribe but
more importantly
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show click that beautiful little
subscribe button
maybe leave a five star review if you're
feeling generous we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you